hey uh can I talk about something about
when you want to give me more of your
money no did you want to do that now we
can go inside
feeling kind of good tonight
I was just um
I'm in love with you what
I'm really sorry if that's weird for you
to hear but I need you to
hear it
probably not in good timing I know that
I just what are you doing
what do you expect me to say to that
well I am
I
can't
you have no idea don't do that
what your friendship needs to be
I don't want to do that
I want to be more than that
I
can't
I'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
your fault
I'm sorry I'm as interpreted our
friendship
so I mean to tell you I want to take you
out for lunch for your last day oh what
do you think tomorrow lunch you and me
okay
you're not leaving tomorrow
you're leaving today right
Maybe
wow so that's it huh just
four o'clock and you were gone for good
why am I so sad
am I doing the wrong thing
absolutely not
it's just that sometimes goodbyes are a
[ __ ]
foreign
goodbye stink
okay all right
so
James Halpert
you started with this company
as a fine young man you know what I
think we should do
I think we should just say the goodbyes
for tomorrow at lunch
oh
okay
and then tomorrow
I can tell you
what a great boss you turned out to be
best boss I ever had
oh shoot
that's my cab all right all right
listen Michael I really I did text Pam
but I know it's okay just give her a hug
all right
I'll see you tomorrow at lunch I am
looking forward to watch
and hearing about what a great Buzz
Light
you got it
I don't get it how could she be sleeping
with you this whole time only sleep with
me twice
what what
she's sleeping with you I'm a fiance
she said she was only sleeping with me
Dunder Mifflin this is Pam
oh hey Mom
no
what did dad say
what did you say to my dad
what after you talked he called my mom
and said he was going to look for an
apartment oh my God Pam I don't know I
nothing
truly nothing I mean I just was honest
with him and I
I'm so sorry I don't know
I'll call him again
fifty percent of marriages end in
divorce
so
it was her parents or my parents
what could Jim have said to make my dad
want to leave my mom
and at what point in our marriage is he
going to say it to me
so what'd he say
was it my fault
he said that you told him how much you
love me
about how you feel when I walk in a room
and about
how you've never doubted for a second
that I'm the woman you want to spend the
rest of your life with
I guess he's never felt that with my mom
even at their best
okay
yeah
so tell me what do you want to be when
you grow up I want to be married and
have a hundred kids so I can have a
hundred friends and no one can say no to
being my friend
uh
hey well uh nice talking with you
Michael back to you Miss Trudy hi
everyone it's one of my favorites did
you get married that's right
uh no why not oh it's never happened
so do you have any kids uh nope do you
have a girlfriend I do okay
Stephen I have a girl okay all right
okay so you didn't get to be what you
wanted to be
hey
I want to say something
I've been trying to be more honest
lately and I just need to say a few
things I did the cold walk just I did it
Michael you couldn't even do that
maybe I should be your boss
wow I feel really good right now
why didn't any of you come to my art
show
I invited all of you that really sucked
it's like sometimes some of you act like
I don't even exist
Jim I called off my wedding because of
you
and now we're not even friends
and things are just like weird between
us and that sucks
and I miss you
you're my best friend before you went to
Stanford
and I really miss you
I shouldn't have been with Roy
there were a lot of reasons to call off
my wedding
but the truth is I didn't care about any
of those reasons until I met you and now
you're with someone else
and that's fine it's whatever that's not
what I'm
I'm not okay my feet really hurt the
thing that I'm just trying to say to you
Jim
and to everyone else in the circle I
guess
is that I miss having fun with you
just you not everyone in the circle
I am gonna go walk in the water now
yeah
good day
[Music]
um
did I ever tell you why I left Scranton
oh
yeah I didn't think I had
well
it was all about Pam
yeah I mean
she was with Roy and uh
I just couldn't take it
I mean I lost it Dwayne
I couldn't sleep
I couldn't concentrate on anything
and weird stuff like
food
had no taste
so my solution was to move away
it was awful
and it is something that I wouldn't wish
on my worst enemy
with you
all right